Good afternoon.
So we're going to continue
our discussion about atomicity
and how to achieve atomicity.
And today the focus
is going to be
on implementing this idea
called recoverability,
which we just described
and defined the last time.
So if you recall from
last time, the idea
is that when you have modules
that interact with one another,
and in this example M1 calls
M2, and M2 fails somewhere
in the middle of this
invocation and it recovers,
the goal here is
to try to make sure
that the invoker of this
module, in this case M1,
or all subsequent
invokers of M1,
don't see any
partial results that
were computed during this
execution when M2 failed.
And this was the idea that
we called recoverability.
And the definition
of recoverability
was that an action,
which is made up
of a composite
sequence of steps is
recoverable from the point
of view of its invoker,
if it looks to the invoker and
to all subsequent invokers as
if this action either
completely occurred,
or if it didn't completely
occur and aborted, it
aborted in such a way that all
partial effects of that action
were undone or backed out.
So in other words,
recoverability is
this idea that you
either do it all,
either complete the action,
or do none of the action.
But the effects
are as if you were
able to back out of the action.
And we use this
idea to then talk
about a particular special
case of recoverability
to implement a
recoverable sector, which
is a single sector
of a disk where
what we were able to do was to
ensure that everybody reading,
we defined a put procedure
and a get procedure.
So, readers would
invoke get.
And we ensure that
everybody doing a get
would never see the
partial results of any put.
So, if a failure were to
happen in the middle of a put,
people doing a get wouldn't
see these partial results.
And, the main idea here
was to actually maintain
what is more generally known as
a shadow version, or a shadow
copy, or a shadow
object of the data,
and we maintained two
versions of the data
that we call D0 and D1.
And, we maintain
a sector that we
call the chooser sector to
choose between the two shadows.
And, what we were able to argue
was that this chooser always
points to the version that
you want people to get from
to read from, and so
when someone does a put,
the idea is first to write
to the version that's
not currently being read from.
So the chooser points to zero.
Then the putter would put
data, write data into one.
And if the failure happened
in the middle of that write,
there's no problem
because people who read
would still read from zero.
And we reduce this
case of proving
this algorithm
correct to the case
when a failure happened in the
middle of writing the chooser
sector.
And we were able to argue
that as long as people,
if a failure happened in
the middle of writing here,
either of these
versions is correct
because a failure
by definition didn't
happen in the middle of writing
either of these two sectors.
And therefore you could
pick either of them
and read from it.
And during this
process, we came up
with this notion which
we're going to generalize
today called a commit point.
The commit point is the point
at which for any action,
the results are visible
to subsequent actions.
And if a failure happens
before the commit point,
then the idea is,
in general, you
would not want people not to
see the partial results that
might have accumulated
before the failure occurred.
And in this particular
case, the commit point
is when the chooser sector gets
written to the current version
of the data.
And that call to writing
the chooser sector returns.
And if it returns, then you
know that people doing a get
will get from the version
that just got written.
So, in the implementation
of recoverable put,
the commit point was
when this call returned.
So now, the question for today
is how we deal with larger
actions --
-- because this is a plan that
works pretty well for single
sector puts and gets.
So, we were able to make
individual sector reads
and writes recoverable.
But if you think about any
serious application or even any
toy application, in most
cases you end up having more
data than what fits
into one single sector.
And, you might have
things touching data all
over the place.
And, our approach to doing this
is to actually first define
what a programmer
must do, what somebody
wishing to write a program
that is a recoverable action
must do.
And then we're going to
implement that underneath
in a system so the
programmer doesn't
have to worry about
implementing recoverability.
So the idea here is
for the programmer
of a recoverable action, to
start writing that action using
a system call, a call that they
call begin recoverable action,
and then discipline
herself or himself
to write some software which
has a small number of rules
as to what can go in here.
And then, explicitly,
when they want
to commit that
recoverable action,
make its results visible
to subsequent actions,
invoke commit.
And then, they are allowed
to do a little bit more work,
or a lot of work here.
But, there's very
strict restrictions
on what they can
do after a commit.
And then, they can end using
end recoverable action.
And this phase here
before the commit
is called the pre-commit phase.
This is the post-commit phase.
And the idea here is
if a failure occurred
here or an abort occurred before
the commit and this action
was made to abort,
then the system
must restore the state
of all of the variables,
and all of the data that was
touched here to the same state
before this action
even got invoked.
OK, it's as if not
of this happened.
So this is the not at all
part of this definition
of recoverability.
Once you reach this point
of the commit returns,
the only thing you're
allowed to do here
are things that cause
you to complete.
You're not allowed
to abort here.
to back out here.
So once you reach
the point, it means
you're in the do it all part
of do it all or none at all.
So you have to complete
all the way to the end.
And what this really
means is that all
of the data that you
want to manipulate,
and all of the resources
that you want to accumulate,
and we'll look at locks as a
resource that you would like to
accumulate in order to
enforce isolation, which
is a topic for
next time, all that
has to happen here so that
once you reach this point
and it ends, then even if
a failure occurs when it
restarts, you just
have to crunch through
and finish what
was going on here.
And that can just happen.
There's nothing to
acquire, no resources
to get all of the data
variables have already
been put in their correct
situation in the correct state.
So the interesting
part really is
what happens between the
begin recoverable action
and until the commit finishes.
And that's really what
we're going to focus on.
Now in addition to commit,
there is another call
that we have to explicitly
think about, and that's abort.
And there's two or
three different ways
in which abort may be invoked.
The first is a program that
might herself or himself have
abort in their code.
For example, in that bank
transfer application,
if you discover that your
savings account doesn't
have enough funds to cover
a transfer, you read it,
and then you maybe
write something,
and then you discover that you
don't have the funds to cover
the transfer.
You might just abort.
And the semantics of
abort are that once abort
is called by the
programmer, they
can be guaranteed that when
the next person invokes
a recoverable action that
involves the same data items,
those readers will see the same
state as if this action never
started.
So what this means is
that the system must
have a plan of undoing
and backing out
of any changes that
might have occurred
before this abort is called.
Another reason an
abort might occur
is that you're in a, for
example, database application,
and you're booking
all sorts of things
like plane tickets, and
air tickets, and hotel
reservations, and so on.
And you book a few
of them and then
you discover you can't get
one of the reservations
that you want.
You might as a user might
abort the whole transaction.
And that causes all the
individual things that
are in partial state to abort.
Another reason why
abort might happen
is that, and we'll see
this the next time when
we talk about locking,
anytime you have locks,
we already saw that
anytime you have locks you
have the danger of deadlock.
In one way in which
the system implementing
these atomic actions, both for
isolation in particular, deals
with deadlocks is when
two or more actions are
waiting for each other, waiting
on locks that the others hold,
you just abort one of them,
or abort as many of them
as needed for
progress to happen.
So the system might
unilaterally decide
to abort certain actions.
And, what that means is that
the systems' abort had better
have a plan to undo all
partial changes that
might have occurred before
it returns from abort.
OK, so that's the general model.
So what we're going
to do today is
to understand what happens
when data variables are written
inside one of these
recoverable actions:
how come it's implemented,
and how abort is implemented.
And that's the plan.
And, once we do
that, we will have
implemented recoverability.
So we're going to study two
solutions to this problem.
And the first solution uses an
idea called version histories.
And version histories
really build on an idea
that we did see last
time when we talked
about recoverable sector,
which is this rule that we call
the golden rule of
recoverability, which
says never modify the only
copy because if you modify
the only copy of something and
a failure occurs, then you don't
really have a way
of backing it out
because you don't know what
the original value was.
Version histories
generalize the idea
to say, never modify anything.
So the idea is anytime you
want to write a variable,
you don't actually
overwrite anything.
You create another
version of the variable
and somehow arrange
for the set of pointers
that, for a variable
to point to all
of the versions of
any given variable.
And to understand that, we need
to understand the difference
between conventional storage,
like a conventional variable
that is also called a cell
store or a cell storage item,
and a variable that allows you
to implement versions which
we're going to call
a journal based storage.
So, cell storage is
traditional storage.
So if you have a variable,
X, that's cell storage
and you set X to some value,
V, what ends up happening
is that the cell that
contains X is you
write the value, V, into X.
In other words, you overwrite
whatever there is you know,
and replace it with V.
And, this overwriting really is
what causes the problem if you
don't have another copy of this
variable somehow maintained,
overwriting means that this
rule of recoverabilities
is being violated.
We're going to use the word
install for these writes.
So we'll be installing
items into cell stores.
So what that means is assigning
a value to a cell store
variable.
And the problem is this gets
in the way of the golden rule.
So what were going to do is
use these cell storage items
that we know how to build
that's the memory abstraction
to build an expanded
version called a journal
storage of generalized
storage in which nothing
is ever overwritten.
The way this works
is that if you
have X, the very first time
you set X to some value,
you end up creating a data
structure in cell storage
that looks like this.
You have a value of V1.
And you also keep track of the
identifier of the action that
created that.
And, that'll turn
out to be useful
for us to know the identifiers
of the actions that
created any given variable.
And how you get
these identifiers?
When begin_ra is called,
it returns an ID, OK,
and the system knows that.
And this ID is available
to the program as well.
Then the next version, if
X gets set by any action
to a different value, what you
do is you created that as V2.
And, you keep track of the
identifier that maintains that.
And then you got V3,
and so on, all the way.
And the current version,
the latest version
might be Vn that
was written by idn.
Now if the same
action repeatedly
writes the same variable,
you just create new versions.
So it isn't like there's
one version per action.
It's just that there's
one version every time
you write something.
So literally, nothing
is overwritten.
And so, that's X.
So, X itself points to the
head version, the very latest
version that was written.
And, you could
imagine that there
are these pointers pulling
you back like a link list.
But the nice thing about it
is this is the journal store.
So, X itself is
this whole thing.
And, we'll implement two
calls that when you have,
this is basically a
memory abstraction.
So, you need to read
and you need to write.
So, for write, we're
going to come up
with a call called write
journal, which in the notes
I think has a slightly
different name.
I think they call
it write new value.
But write journal makes it clear
that it's for journal store.
And, this is easy.
It's some data item, X.
It's some value, V.
And, it's the ID of the
action that's doing the write.
And this is very
easy to implement.
All you do is you
create a new version.
And then you take the current
thing that X is pointing to,
and make the current version's
next pointer point to that.
And then you make X
point to the new version.
So, it's just a
link list thing, OK?
And, in addition
to write journal,
we obviously need to
implement read journal.
And read journal is going to
take a data item that you wish
to read, X, and for reasons
that will become clearer
in a minute, it also takes
the ID of the action that
wants to do the read, OK?
So if you want to
read something,
the idea is going to be the
following: the idea is going
to be that some of these
actions are actions;
some of these versions are
going to have been written
by actions that were committed.
OK, and some of
these actions were
going to have been
written by actions
that started writing things and
then maybe failed or aborted.
So they never committed.
Now, clearly when
you do read journal,
you don't want to see the
results of those actions that
were never committed
because what you want
to see from the definition
that we laid out
are once you reach
the commit point,
you want to see the
change is visible.
Before that, you don't
want anything visible.
So as long as you can
keep track of which
of these actions committed, and
which of these didn't commit,
you can implement read journal
by starting at the most
recent version,
and going backwards
until you find the first
version that corresponds
to a value that was written by
an action that was committed.
So what you need to do is start
from here and look at IDN.
If IDN, you need to maintain
another table that tells you
whether IDN committed or not.
If it committed, then
return that value.
If not, go back one.
And, keep going until you
find the most recent version
that was written by
a committed action.
If you do that, then
read journal clearly
returns to you what
you would want,
which is the value
that was written
by the last committed action.
The only other tweak
that you want to do,
and the reason why ID is
passed as an argument read
journal is if the current
action has already written,
so let's say you are
implementing an action
and you set the
value of X to 17,
then when you read
the value of X,
you would want the
value that you set.
I mean, you wouldn't want
the previous committed action
that's one way of
defining read journal.
So as you go from the most
recent version to the oldest
version, you either look see
whether the value that you
are reading now is a value that
you set, your own action set.
And if it was, just return that.
And then, it'll return
to you the last value
that this action set.
Otherwise, you keep
going until you
find the value set by the
most recent committed action.
And since we aren't dealing here
with concurrent actions at all,
right, we've already said last
time that, until next Monday,
we're only going to be dealing
with one action at a time.
There's no concurrent actions.
Clearly, this algorithm
will be correct.
You start from the
most recent version,
keep going until you find the
first version that was either
done by this action
that's doing the read,
or the first version that
was written by an action that
committed.
So, clearly what this means
is that you need a table
that you have to maintain
that stores the status
of these different actions.
It needs to store which
actions committed,
and which actions didn't commit.
And that's going to be done
using a data structure called
the commit record table.
And this is a very simple table.
It just has ID1,
ID2, all the way down
to whatever ID's you have.
Every time somebody calls begin
RA, you return them an ID,
and then you create
this table that as soon
as they create this action,
you set their state to pending,
which I'll call P, OK?
And, any time an action
commits, you replace this P
with a C, which is
a commit record.
OK, and once it's replaced
with a C for an action,
this item is called the
commit record for an action.
So now, when you want
to do read journal
and you're looking to see
whether for any given action,
things were committed,
the corresponding action
is committed or not,
you look at this.
You see its IDN.
You look for IDN in this table,
C, if it's committed or not.
If it's not committed, then
you go to the previous version
and you do the same thing.
If it's committed,
then you return it.
Now, it's not actually clear
why you need this pending thing
here.
But it'll turn out that you will
require the pending thing when
you deal with
isolation on Monday.
So for now, you don't have
to worry about the fact
that these pending
things are there, OK?
Now, suppose an action
starts, and then it aborts.
So I mentioned here that when
an action starts and it aborts,
the system has to do some kind
of undoing of data in order
for abort to be
correctly implemented.
So, the state of the system's
restored to the state
before the action even started.
The nice thing about this way of
implementing version histories
and read journal
is you don't have
to do anything on an abort.
If the application or
the system called abort,
nothing has to be done because
read journal basically is just
going scanning this
backward, looking
for whether the version
was written by itself,
that same action or looking for
whether the version was written
by a committed action.
So as long as you can
find for any given ID
whether it was committed or
not, that's all you need.
OK, but just for completeness,
and this will become useful
the next time, all we'll do when
abort is called on an action,
so abort takes the ID of
the action as an argument,
all we'll do is we'll
replace, if ID7 aborts,
we'll just replace the pending.
We'll replace that
with an abort, OK?
So, this commit
record table contains
the status of the actions.
And that status could either be
committed, pending, or aborted.
When it starts, it's pending.
And then it's pending as long as
either it aborts, in which case
it aborted, or it's committed.
Now, if it just fails and you
don't do anything about it,
and there's no abort
call, it'll continue
to remain in the pending state.
But that's OK because
we're never really going
to read the value
of anything that's
the in the pending state that
was set by an action that's
in the pending state.
So is this clear?
OK, this approach is
actually quite reasonable
except that it has
a few problems.
The first problem
it has is, well, it
has two related problems.
And that's the first class
of problems that it has is
that although it looks
like we've really
nailed this problem of achieving
recoverable storage using
this journal storage
idea, building
general recoverable actions so
that for any variable that's
read inside here or read
inside a recoverable action,
you use this general
storage idea.
It's not quite correct
because you have to ask,
what happens if the system
fails while the system is
writing this commit record?
So, the application
calls commit.
The system's starting to
write this commit record
and it fails.
Or you might more
generally ask, what
happens if I create this new
version in write journal,
and as I'm creating a new
version of a variable,
the system crashes.
So some garbage
got written here.
Or more likely, some garbage
got written not in here
but as I was changing
this pointer for X
to point to the
most recent version,
some garbage got written.
So, all subsequent reads
of X don't quite work.
The answer to this
question is that we
know how to solve this problem
because that question is
basically identical.
Both of these are identical.
If we know how to solve
the problem of writing
a single, recoverable sector,
a single, small item of data,
then we know how to solve
these two problems because both
of these are writing recoverably
a small amount of data.
In one case, a
pointer that takes
X to point to the most recent
version, in another case
it's a single data
item that corresponds
to the commit record in
this commit record table.
And so this shows this
idea of bootstrap,
that in order to build
this atomic action,
this recoverable action, we end
up
[SOUND OFF/THEN ON]
...and then you bootstrap on...
...and then you bootstrap on
something that we know
already how to do
because there are these cases
where you have to make sure
that writes to
certain pointers,
and some table items
are done atomically.
And we know how to do that
because we just told you
how to do recoverable sectors.
And you could just take
shadowed objects
for these items, and
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
to get this bootstrap.
So that's the first thing that...
the first step problem.
There's another problem, not
so much a correctness problem,
but a problem in general
using these version
histories in order to
build recoverable actions.
Any ideas on what that might be?
Like, why would we
want to use this?
Student: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
Is this a space?
Well, you kind of can't
really get around that.
I mean, it's true that
there are these older
versions that you keep forever.
But, there are
optimizations you can
bring to bear that are
beneath these old versions that
you don't really care about
anymore. Because really
the read only
requires, at least for the way
we [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
about this when we talk
about isolation tomorrow.
But really, the
read only
requires for a
single action case
the last committed version.
So, you could garbage collect
this stuff if you want.
Student: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
Yeah, it's really slow.
So, for applications
where you care
about performance, or
reasonable performance,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
this is really slow.
And naturally, it's
not to say that this
is a bad idea, an idea that
shouldn't be used at all.
In fact, it's a perfectly
good idea for many cases
where you might,
for various reasons,
want to store restorative
records of old data
and you don't care about fast
read or write performance.
So it's perfectly good
for certain applications.
But it's not good for
applications that want
reasonably high-performance.
And the reason that
this thing is small
is because if you
think about it,
it actually optimizes what you
might think of as uncommon case
because what it ensures is that
when you fail and you recover,
you have to do no work.
So crash recovery is really
fast in this approach
because there's nothing to
be done for crash recovery.
But reads and writes are
slow because a read involves
traversing the list.
A write involves doing some
[UNINTELLIGIBLE  PHRASE].
And so, it almost
optimizes the opposite
of what you would want.
If you want to
write performance,
you want to form the principle
of optimizing the common case.
And in order to optimize the
common case, what it means,
what you want to do here is
to make the reads and writes
really fast, and
maybe pay the penalty
of a little bit of extra
timing in dealing with
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
[LAUGHTER]
It's working now?
Hello?
Technician: Sorry.
All right, thanks.
OK, so what you want to do
is optimize, whoa, it's loud.
[LAUGHTER]
So the integral of the volume
over time is correct.
OK, so the solution
to this problem
where we want to optimize
the common case of reads
and writes, but we are
OK taking a bunch of time
to do crash recovery is
an idea called logging.
So the way to think of a log
is it's like a version history
except you don't have a
version for each variable.
You think of it as an Interleaf
version data structure
that interleaves all the version
histories for all of the data
that was ever written
during an action,
during all of the
actions that ran.
So what this means is that you
can write the log sequentially.
And you've seen this
in yesterday's paper
where they use logs for
a different application
for high performance in a
file system for a system
where writes normally
would incur a lot of seeks.
But you can use the same idea.
In this case, we're going to
use a log for crash recovery.
But the fundamental property
of a log data structure
is that it needs be
written only sequentially.
And we know that disks
do that pretty fast.
It's only when you have
to seek that and read
small chunks of data with
seeks that you end up
being really slow.
So we're going to use cell
storage to satisfy our reads
and writes.
So all of those are going
to go to cell stores.
You can read means
you just read a variable.
You don't traverse any
link lists, and writes
you don't create
any new versions.
You just write into cell store.
But then the log is going to be
stored on a nonvolatile medium
such as a disk.
And it's written sequentially.
So once we have those two, our
plan is going to be as follows.
And this plan is the
same plan that's adopted.
Although there is
dozens of ways of doing
log based crash recover,
they all essentially follow
the same basic plan.
You read and write
normally to cell storage.
And you also write
a copy of what
you're reading and writing.
You write an encoding
of what you're writing,
any updates that you
make into the log.
OK, and we'll talk
in more detail
about what you're exactly
right into the log
and when you write
into the log, OK?
So that allows us to follow this
golden rule of recoverability.
It'll turn out that the
log is a copy of the data.
So you always have two copies of
the data: one in cell storage,
one on the log.
So what happens when you fail?
Well, when you fail, unlike in
the version history case where
you could fail and restart, and
you don't have to do anything,
here when you fail, the system
runs a recovery procedure.
And that recovery procedure
recovers from the log
that we have conveniently
arranged to write
in the non-volatile storage.
So, it remains
even after a crash,
and it remains after
a crash recovers.
And there are two things to do
while recovering from the log.
For actions that didn't get to
finish the commit, for actions
that were uncommitted,
which is this commit never
return, what we have to
do is to look carefully
to see whether the corresponding
cell store had any updates that
were made to it.
And it'll turn out
that the log is
going to help us keep track
of what items were updated
by any given action.
And what we're going
to end up doing
is for uncommitted actions,
we're going to back out.
In other words, we're going to
undo any changes that it made,
and the log is going
to help us do that.
And conversely, for
committed actions,
because the semantics we
want are that once committed,
you would like the changes to
be visible to other people.
For committed actions,
what you would like to do
are to make sure
that the changes made
by all committed
actions are in fact
installed in the cell store.
And what this means is
that if they turn out
to not have been
installed, and we're
going to use the log to tell us
whether they've been installed
or not, we will
redo those actions.
And, the second
thing we need to do
is what happens if
an abort is called
either by the application
or by the system.
Well, in this case, what we
have to do is to use the log,
and to keep track,
the log is going
to help us keep track of the
changes made by this action
to the cell store.
The cell store itself doesn't
have an ocean of old or new
because it's overwritten.
So the log is going
to tell us that.
And when abort is
called, we just
want to back out by undoing the
changes of the current action.
And that's the plan.
So the first thing
we need to figure out
is what this log looks like.
So as we saw from
this discussion,
the log is going to be required
for us to do two things.
We're going to be undoing
things from the log,
and we're going to be
redoing things from the log.
So what that suggests is that
any time you update cell store,
you change X from 17 to 25.
What you'd really
like to maintain
is what the value was before the
change was made so that you can
undo if you need to,
and what the value
is after the change was made so
that you can redo if you have
to if by chance the
actual cell store didn't
get written at the right time.
So really the way to think
about logging base crash
recover is that
the log is really
the authoritative
version of the data.
The cell store itself is you
should think of as a cache.
And we've seen this idea before.
The cell store you should
think of as a cache.
If a failure happens,
you really have
to be careful about
trusting the cell store.
And, you don't trust
what's in the cell store.
You start with a log,
and by selectively
undoing certain
changes that were made
and redoing certain
changes, you produce
a more pristine, correct version
of the data, which corresponds
to the changes made by all
the committed actions being
visible, and the changes made
by all the uncommitted actions
being wiped away to
the previous version.
OK, so what does
the log look like?
Well, as I've already said, a
log is like a version history
except it interleaves
everything,
and it's sequential.
So it's really an
append-only data structure.
And there's a few
different kinds of records
that the log maintains.
In particular, two are going
to be interesting to us.
So there are two types of
records that we care about.
The first type are
update records,
which are written
to the log whenever
a cell store item changes.
So, if X goes from 17 to 25,
what you would write
is an update record
that looks like this.
You store the ID
of the transaction,
sorry, ID of the recoverable
action that did the update.
And then, you store two items.
One of them is an undo item
or an undo action, actually.
And, an undo that might
say  and a redo action.
So what this means
here is that let's say
that the actual
step of this action
said X is assigned
to some value, new.
In the log, what
you would write is
keep track of old value,
the current value of X,
and make that the undo step.
And then, keep track of
the change that was made
and make that the real step.
So now, after doing this,
if the system were to fail,
and this action 172 were
to never commit then
you can systematically
start with the log,
start with the latest
item in the log
and go backwards, and
undo any changes made
by actions that didn't commit.
And conversely, and you might
need to do this as well,
you might want to look at all
the actions that committed,
and make sure that all those
actions, those individual steps
in those actions are redone so
that once the crash recovers,
you have a correct
version of the data.
Now the other thing
that you will need,
and you'll see why in a moment,
is another kind, a record
and a log, which we're going
to call the outcome record.
And this outcome
is the thing that
keeps track of whether an
action committed or not.
Remember I said you're going
to look through the log
and figure out which
actions committed,
and which didn't commit.
You need to store
that somewhere.
In particular, what that means
is that when an action commits,
you had better make sure that
there is in it them in the log
because the log really is
the only correct version
of the data.
So you have an outcome
record, and this
has an ID of the action.
It might be 174.
And, there's a status
that might stay committed.
And other values for the
status might be aborted
is a possible value
of the status.
Another is pending.
So for various
reasons, what we will
have is when begin recoverable
action returns with an ID,
we will create a
log entry that says
that this action has begun.
So you might have
a begin record.
It's not that important
to worry about for now.
But the status of a committed
record and an aborted,
and the update type are
important to understand.
So once you have this
log structure understood,
or the log data
structure understood,
what you have to
think about our there
are two questions that you
end up spending a lot of time
thinking about in designing
these log-based protocols.
The first one is when
to write the log.
And the second one is,
you know, I sort of
said you just look
through the log
and undo the guys
who didn't commit,
and redo the people
who committed.
But you have to be very
careful about doing that.
And that corresponds
to this question
of exactly how to recover,
how to systematically recover
so the state of the system is
as I have described before.
So those are the questions
we're going to deal
with for the next few minutes.
Let's do this with
a specific example.
And it will turn
out and to answer
doesn't really depend
on the example.
But the example is good to
give you the right intuition.
And this example is actually
pretty common example
of a disk-bound database.
So a disk bound
database is one where
you have applications
writing to a database, which
is where the cell
storage is implemented.
And the cell storage is on disk.
So, you might have
writes of cell items, X,
and they go to a database.
And similarly, in any
disk bound database
that you want
crash recovery for,
you need to maintain a log.
And for various reasons
having to do primarily
with dealing with failures
of the disk hardware itself,
it's very often useful
to an experience
to maintain the log
on a different disk.
So we'll maintain
for this example
the log on a different disk.
So whenever write X is done,
just looking at the log data
structure, you need to
write an update record
and append that to the log.
So at some point you would
need to write this to the log.
You need to log the update --
-- that says that X change from
something to something else.
So the question is, when
do you write both of these?
So one approach might be that
it really doesn't matter.
As long as the log gets
the data, you're fine.
But that has a
couple of problems.
In particular,
suppose you write X
without writing the log entry.
And as soon as you write
X, before you have a chance
to write to the log,
you crash, or the system
causes this program to abort,
or the program itself aborts.
It writes X and then it
does some calculation
and the it decides to abort.
Now you are in trouble because
the log hasn't kept track yet
the log hasn't had
a chance of keeping
track of what the
old value was, which
means that if you
really want to restore
this database by
undoing this write to X,
you have to do a
whole lot of work.
And it might be
impossible to do it.
If you didn't know, for example,
what the current value was,
there was absolutely
no way for you
to restore to the old value.
So what this suggests is
that you better not write
to the cell store before
you write to the log
because if you wrote to
the cell store log write,
and the system crashed right
after or failure about it,
you won't really
have a way in general
of reverting to the
version of the data item
before this write.
And you do need to revert
because it just aborted
or fails.
So you need to back out of
all changes that were made.
So that suggests the
first part of our protocol
which we are going to
call the wall protocol.
Actually, that is the wall,
I mean, not the first part.
This suggests this
wall protocol.
Wall stands for
write-ahead logging.
And the protocol says update
the log or append to the log
before you write
to the cell store.
It's what it says.
Write ahead log says write the
log before you write the cell
store.
The advantage of writing the
log before you write to the cell
store is that suppose now
you set X to some value
and then you crashed.
Then you're guaranteed that
if the cell store got written,
the log got written, which
means that if this action didn't
commit, you can
go through the log
and undo that action because
you know that the log entry got
written correctly before
the cell store got written.
And if the log entry
didn't get written,
then you know the
cell store didn't
get written, which means you
don't have to undo anything
for that particular data item.
So either way you're fine.
There is another
part of this protocol
that we're going to need
to meet the semantics
of a recoverable
action that we wanted,
which is that once
you reach commit,
you want the changes
made by that action
to be visible to all
the other people,
all of the other actions
that are subsequent actions.
And what that means is
that before you return
from the commit, you
had better make sure
that the commit record for this
action is logged to the disk,
is logged, because if you didn't
do that, and you just returned,
then you can't be guaranteed
that all of the writes that
were done to the cell
item were actually
put on to the cell store.
There's no guarantee
that these writes
to the cell store actually
got written to the cell
store because all you are
doing in this protocol
is ensuring that the
writes to the log
are being written before
the writes to the data.
Nobody is saying when the
writes of the cell store
really are happening
and finishing,
which means if the
action commits,
and you return committed to
the user to the application,
then you had better have
a way of making sure
that if the failure
now happened,
the system when
it recovers knows
that this action committed,
which means it follows, then,
that if you want those
semantics that you'd better
write the commit record, the
fact that this action committed
to the log before
the commit returns.
And really the only reason
you need that is that
we've established; we've decided
that we wanted the semantics
that a different action commits,
you want the results to be
visible to everybody else.
And later on, we'll see
that this is related
to this notion of durability.
So write commit record before --
returning for commit.
So two main ideas: write
ahead logging means
make sure that you write
the log, append to the log
before you write
to the cell store.
And in order to make sure that
committed actions, the results
of committed actions are
visible even after failure
to subsequent actions,
log the commit record
before you return
from the commit.
So now we are
actually in good shape
to specify this
recovery procedure
that I've alluded to
before because the log is
going to contain these update
records and these outcome
records.
And that's going to
allow us to decide
what to do upon crash recovery.
And actually the
only other piece
we need is to decide
what happens on an abort.
And that's actually
pretty straightforward.
If the system calls abort,
or if the user application
calls abort on an action,
what abort has to do
is to look through the log.
Remember that all of the
rights have been written.
Any time a write happens,
you don't actually
care about when
the write actually
happens at the cell store.
What you care about is that
the write happens to the log
before the write happens
to the cell store.
So, if an abort were
called, all you have to do
is to ensure that
before abort returns,
all of the actions done
by, all of the steps taken
by this action around done, and
the corresponding cell values
are on done.
And that's all you have to
do when you implement abort.
So one thing that I haven't
really specified very clearly
is when the actual
writes happen to the disk
or to any cell store.
And it turns out that it
really doesn't matter.
If there's no failure,
as long as you ensure,
you could have
caches in the middle.
You could have anything else.
So, as long as you ensure that
if there's no concurrency,
we'll deal with that next time.
But as long as you
ensure that when
you have actions that come
one after the other that
are recoverable that
the values that are read
are only the values that
were written by previously
committed actions,
then it really
doesn't matter when those
were actually written to disk.
But for crash recover to work,
the main thing that matters is
make sure that the log keeps
track exactly of all the things
to undo for uncommitted actions.
And for things
that got committed,
to make sure that the log keeps
track of the commit record
before the commit returns.
So given the story, the
way the recovery procedure
works as the following.
The first step is the system
fails, and that it recovers.
You scan the log backwards.
And as you are scanning
the log backwards,
you keep track of
two kinds of actions.
You keep track of actions that
were either committed or were
aborted, OK?
And what that means
is that for actions
that were committed or
aborted, the cell store
for those actions is
in a certain state
or needs to be in
a certain state.
For committed actions,
it needs to be
in a state that's the result of
finishing the committed action.
And for the aborted
actions, what it means
is that when the abort
returned and there
was an aborted
action, abort already
undid the state
of the cell store
by definition by the definition
of the abort procedure.
So what that means is
for log records that
contain a type outcome
and the status abort
that you don't
have to do anything
because the changes are
already on done before
that abort record was written.
So what you do in
scanning the log backwards
is you build up two
kinds of actions.
You build up winners,
which are actions
that were committed or aborted.
And you build up a list of
losers that were none of these.
In other words, they
were pending actions
that kind of just during a
failure they were pending,
so they didn't commit.
And they were never aborted.
And so the plan
now is to make sure
that the cell store is correctly
restored to the state that
was before the crash where
all of the committed actions'
results are visible, and none
of the uncommitted actions,
you know, all of
those are blown away.
All you have to do is
to redo the winners that
were committed.
You don't have to do anything
for the aborted winners
because they were
already undone.
So you have to redo
committed winners,
and you have to undo any
changes made by losers, right,
because these
losers by definition
were things that didn't
commit or didn't abort.
And the reason you only redo the
committed winners rather than
all winners is it makes no
sense to redo aborted winners.
And you don't need to undo
them because they were already
undone when the abort record
was written to the log.
So this is the basic
idea for dealing
with one of these databases.
But there's five or
six optimizations
that end up making this
kind of system go faster.
You'll see some of these
optimizations buried
inside the system R paper, which
is the discussion for tomorrow.
But what I'll do on Monday,
I'll spend five minutes talking
about the most
important optimizations,
and I think the whole
story will become clear.
So the plan for the subsequent
lectures on this topic
are: on Monday we'll
deal with isolation,
and on Wednesday we'll continue
to talk about isolation,
and then talk about a
different issue of consistency.